[Música]
eeuu continúa en vilo dos días después
de las elecciones presidenciales
mientras sigue el conteo de votos en
cinco estados georgia carolina del norte
nevada pensilvania y alaska donald trump
renovó sus acusaciones de fraude sin
ningún tipo de prueba y comenzó una
batalla legal para un reconteo de
papeletas bailén acumula 264 votos
electorales y está a 6 de los necesarios
para ganar consuma 214
agitada noche de protestas la mayoría
pacíficas en los estados que siguen el
conteo de votos y otras ciudades que ya
finalizaron el escrutinio sin embargo se
registraron algunos disturbios en nueva
york' y en portland donde hubo decenas
de detenidos incluso saqueos
francia reforzará sus controles
fronterizos duplicando el número de
policías a 4.800 así lo informó el
presidente de manuel macrón durante su
visita a la frontera con españa en medio
de una creciente amenaza terrorista
[Música]
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu donde el candidato
demócrata joe biden tiene la ventaja en
estas elecciones y va ganando en los
estados de michigan y wisconsin mientras
que el candidato presidente de donald
trump pide un reconteo de los votos en
los estados donde los resultados no son
favorables para él pero veamos cómo está
el mapa electoral hasta el momento yo
bailan acumula 264 votos electorales y
estaba 6 de los necesarios para ganar es
decir de los 270 mientras que donald
trump acumula 214 y es que la campaña de
reelección del mandatario republicano
impugnó el conteo de votos en wisconsin
y michigan donde los medios proyectaron
el triunfo del candidato demócrata
además de pensilvania estado en el que
bailen lleva desventaja pero falta el
conjunto de zonas tradicionalmente
demócratas
y es que varias ciudades estadounidenses
vivieron durante la jornada de ver
multitudinarias protestas poselectorales
a favor y en contra de ambos candidatos
los simpatizantes de donald trump exigen
el recuento de todos los votos o
paralizar su conteo mientras que quienes
votaron por bailén piden que se respete
el proceso democrático y que finalice el
conteo de las papeletas enviadas por
correo aunque la mayoría de las
protestas fueron pacíficas algunas se
transformaron en disturbios o
produciendo decenas de arrestos como
nueva york es donde incluso hubo saqueos
al igual que en portland en oregón
mientras tanto en filadelfia pensilvania
michigan ya 30 georgia los manifestantes
de lado y lado estuvieron reunidos en
torno a los centros de conteo para
apoyar a sus candidatos andrés meza
muños tiene todos los detalles
cada voto cuenta
[Música]
esta consigna se extiende por todo eeuu
en medio de las protestas que exigen que
nada detenga el conteo de las papeletas
de las elecciones presidenciales estamos
aquí porque donald trump hizo un falso
reclamo de victoria díganlo conmigo un
falso reclamo de victoria
a menos que la gente se ponga de pie y
deje en claro que cada voto tiene que
ser contado la elección será robadas a
medida que yo by the end ganaba terreno
el presidente de donaldson denunciaba
fraudes sin ningún fundamento su campaña
emprendió acciones legales e instó a que
no se reciban más votos por correo en
pensilvania a recontar las papeletas de
wisconsin y a detener los conteos en
georgia y michigan su llamado hizo que
sus simpatizantes acudieran en masa al
centro de conteo en la ciudad de dicho
hoy para exigir que se detenga el
escrutinio
[Aplausos]
marian derrotó a trauma en michigan y
wisconsin por un estrecho margen la
campaña de trauma exige que sus
observadores estén presentes en el
escrutinio los ojos están ahora en
nevada donde el conteo continúa pero los
resultados empezarán a ser revelados
este jueves
vamos a washington 10 y con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
nuevamente lo saludamos los republicanos
tienen un plan para disputar los
resultados electorales en arizona han
convocado a una marcha en un centro de
votación en fin excel para proteger su
voto y vigilar el conteo que dicen los
números en ese estado
raúl se están congregando ya en el
centro de votación en el condado de
maricopa en este condado está la ciudad
de phoenix una de las ciudades más
grandes del estado de arizona ya
reportes locales están diciendo que
hombres armados están allá en este
centro de votación para pues proteger y
vigilar el conteo de votos que los
republicanos y el partido de donald
trump espera pueda revertir la situación
la tendencia que en este momento le
favorece a joe biden pero pues lo que
están diciendo las cifras es que en este
momento yo bailé lleva una delantera del
55% contra el 48 1 por ciento de la
votación a favor de su partido demócrata
esto es aproximadamente 70.000 votos a
favor que le llevan los demócratas a los
republicanos con un 86% de conte un dato
interesante a tener en cuenta en arizona
es que según medios locales faltan
600.000
fotos por correo por contar y esto es
importante porque la tendencia nacional
es que el voto por correo tiende a
favorecer a los demócratas tiende a
darle más apoyo a los demócratas algo
que pues no ayudaría a esta esperanza
que tienen los republicanos de revertir
ese estado y revertir entonces pues
estos 11 votos electorales que ofrece en
arizona último dato sobre arizona a la a
las nueve de la noche hora del este de
eeuu habrá una actualización sobre los
votos en ese estado y sabremos mucho
mejor si pues se concreta ya este estado
para los demócratas
cristóbal otro estado con las miradas de
todos es nevada donde aún según las
estimaciones de la agencia ap falta a un
25 por ciento del conteo hasta ahora
bailén lleva una ventaja muy ajustada le
pregunto qué está en juego allí
sí sí en arizona la diferencia era
apenas de 70.000 votos en nevada es de
8000 raúl y hay mucho en juego falta por
contar una cifra parecida adhesiones
entre 20 20 por ciento de los votos en
este momento pues hay ya un 80 por
ciento contado y el juego está esos 6
votos electorales 6 votos electorales
que si yo bailé mantiene esta victoria
en arizona y gana nevada y esos 6 votos
electorales ajustaría entonces estos 270
otros electorales que le darían la
presidencia esa es la cifra que hay que
alcanzar en tema de números de votos
electorales para alcanzar la casa blanca
sobre la casa blanca le doy un dato
curioso esta mañana cuando caminábamos
por allá nos dimos cuenta que las luces
estuvieron apagadas durante el amanecer
algo muy atípico porque normalmente la
casa tiene la casa blanca tiene la
iluminación nocturna pues amaneció sin
luces otro dato importante al medio día
hora del este de eeuu habrá
actualización de datos en nevada y se
podrá conocer mucho más el panorama de
la votación allá y pues sea este estado
lo ganó hace cuatro años hillary clinton
pequeño y es lo que espera los
demócratas mantener esa esa victoria en
nevada incertidumbre en eeuu cristóbal
gracias por información por supuesto muy
pendientes a lo que ocurra en ese país
en cuanto a estas elecciones
presidenciales cambiamos ahora de
información y vamos hasta francia donde
el presidente de manuel macro and
reforzará sus controles fronterizos
duplicando el número de policías a 4.800
el aumento de los controles apuntaría a
la inmigración ilegal en medio de una
creciente amenaza terrorista que hace
hemos decidido duplicar las fuerzas
desplegadas en las fronteras en el marco
de este control aunque toxo controles
que ver con lupa son lo cual significa
que pasaremos de 2400 a 4800 policías
gendarmes militares y agentes
antidisturbios que serán movilizados
para luchar contra la inmigración
destino el presidente de kosovo hashim
thaçi dimitió este jueves tras
confirmarse las acusaciones de crímenes
de guerra en un tribunal internacional
por su etapa como líder de la guerrilla
albanokosovar que luchó contra las
fuerzas serbias a finales de la década
de los 90 casi anunció que viajará a la
haya sede del tribunal especial para
kosovo tec para entregarse de forma
voluntaria y defender ante esa corte su
inocencia sin embargo anunció cuando se
expresaría hasta ese lugar
navas tiene razón como prometí no
permitirá bajo ninguna circunstancia que
un presidente de la república de kosovo
comparezca ante el tribunal presentó ser
públicos egos ojos por lo tanto con el
fin de proteger la integridad de la
presidencia de la república de kosovo la
integridad del estado de kosovo y la
dignidad de los ciudadanos de kosovo y
respetando la asociación con la
comunidad internacional renunció hoy al
cargo de presidente de la república de
kosovo
continuamos con el avance de eta
convertido ahora en tormenta tropical el
antes huracán tocó tierra en honduras
luego de pasar por nicaragua donde dejó
al menos cuatro personas fallecidas y
graves inundaciones las autoridades
hondureñas admitieron que las lluvias
serán catastróficas y recomendaron
evacuar a unas 30.000 personas es la
sitios seguros en panamá el fenómeno
natural deja ya al menos 8 personas
desaparecidas entre ellos dos niños
hasta que el informativo continue con
nosotros
[Música]